ukrainian tennis player leonid
stanislavski says he's too frightened to
leave his house in kharkiv in northeast
ukraine
russian bombs have landed close to his
home like millions of ukrainians his
life has been turned upside down by the
wall
just a few months ago the 97 year old
was celebrating after the guinness world
records named him the oldest competitive
tennis player in the world
when leonid was in spain competing in
the super seniors world championship he
played a friendly match against tennis
champion rafa nadal
it made headlines around the world
it was outstanding to meet him no one
could have imagined that so soon after
there would be war what has happened now
is simply horrible the world should do
everything it can to stop the war people
on both sides should not be dying while
others are standing
leonid has survived one world war he
worked as an engineer building warplanes
to fight the nazis his daughter is in
poland but he says it's too difficult
for him to get there so he'll stay in
kharkiv and wait for the fighting to
stop
i never thought that i would have to
live through another frightening war
where people on both sides are dying
mothers are losing their children wives
are losing their husbands it needs to be
stopped
before the russian invasion leonid
dreamed of playing against tennis star
roger federer
but now he only has one wish to survive
victoria gatenbee al jazeera